hey y'all it's hewitty and i'm going
undercover on the internet
and it's actually me
[Music]
okay here is cora
what is cora who is sweetie so witty is
an icy girl
so witty is a college grad she went to
usc in san diego state
sweetie is a musician she puts out slaps
for the summertime
sweetie is a hustler she's been an
entrepreneur since
seven eight years old i used to do bake
sales so witty is a philanthropist she
cares about the community
all of my proceeds from pot went to
black lives matter foundation
and i've also started my own foundation
which i have not announced yet
sweetie is a fashionista you know your
girl loves dressing up your girl likes
putting in a cute little weave a cute
little frontal some cute hair you know i
like making it do what it do
you feel me posted how old is sweetie
sweetie is 25 and you know she's
timeless she has no age she looks young
as hell because when i take off all this
makeup
i look like i'm 12 years old so sweetie
is timeless
[Laughter]
what is sweetie's ethnicity well my mama
is filipino chinese and my dad is black
sweetie is tri-racial but that's what
she is
next what is the best song of sweetie
it really depends on what kind of mood
you're in if you want some motivation
icy girl too many if you just you know
fill in the vibe
hot boy agua and if you're trying to
turn up my
type and tap in so make sure you tap
tap tap in submit
i am db
july 2nd 1990 wrong gear in hayward
california wrong city diamante is
missing
the accent over the e chiamo valentin
it's supposed to be a space and harper
so i think there's like five eras
on this thing
i was born in santa clara i was raised
in hayward diamante needs
an accent and kiava and valente need a
space
between kiava and valentine
no seriously it's actually me wikipedia
[Music]
she began writing music at the age of
13.
after high school she went to attend san
diego state university before
transferring to usc where she studied
communication
and business after graduating she began
to focus on her rap career
yes wikipedia i ain't got no corrections
when i was 13 i wrote poetry and once i
figured out that you know
rap was basically poetry over a beat and
that's when i absolutely
fell in love with rap music college i
love the parties
san diego state is a party school usc
has
the role so you know the parties was
cracking and when it came to like
midterms
tests projects 20 page essays
i wanted to drop out all the time so i'm
like all right girl you're already here
so why not just give it your all
i graduated i believe with like a 3.6
i'm just so happy that i'm
now doing music because sitting in the
classes and thinking about music was
very frustrating so
i'm happy i'm finally living out my
dream
sweetie began posting short wraps on her
instagram around 2016.
one video featured her rapping over the
beat kaia's my neck my back
which would eventually turn into icy
girl yes
that title kind of turned me into the
brand i am today if i wouldn't have
called that icy girl because me and my
homegirl was going back and forth
and we were like what should we call
this track so we called this track i see
girl
because i named the icy girl i am now
the icy girl i heard my neck my back
when i was probably like nine
and i remember wrapping the song in the
bathroom i remember
my uncle banging on the door tongue by
you so you're going to be singing that
song and i got in trouble but
as a young person i didn't know the
meaning
behind those lyrics so i was just you
know living my best life wrapping my
neck my back
twitter
[Music]
in icy girl remix sweetie says she's
from sac
and in my type she claims from the bay
which one is it girl
leslie alyssa girl you know what it is
and you know what time it is and i'm
tired of y'all trolls
coming for me i represent the bay area
in sacramento and y'all know
that i do so the fact that y'all are
just doing this to hop
on the the whatever sweetie train when
people are trying to you know come for
me
is hella boosie i was raised in the bay
area and i went to high school in
sacramento
and the reason why i rep sacramento is
because i feel like those teenage years
really have some input and contributing
to who you are as a person
i represent the bay area in sacramento
and i've made that
clear several times so girl pay
attention
posted doesn't it sound like sweetie
says
eight inch bagel that's goodbye
and my type me and the man are having a
debate and i would appreciate it
if y'all were on my side okay thanks bye
eight inch big
oh that's good pipe that's my type
that's my
type i don't hear they go nowhere i mean
i do like eating bagels with butter or
cream cheese in the morning but
i don't hear you know bagel so i don't
know where i got that from
the mick instagram
i am still confused on how to pronounce
your name okay
so my mama and my daddy name me diamante
and don't forget the accent over to e
if you spanish you say my name so
beautifully i have
spanish teachers say my name properly
michelle she's on my team she's
dominican so go ahead and say diamante
grow
diamante i know that's right
so that's how you pronounce my name
ah nice what part of the philippines is
your mom from my mom is from tondo
manila
next one what are these braids called
you know these are called the sweetie
braids i know they was called something
else but i
i've seen a lot of girls you know tapped
in with this hairstyle after i did it so
i'mma call these the sweetie braids
how does it feel to know that no one in
the world is prettier than you
oh that's so sweet oh thank you girl you
know i want pretty girls to know they
gotta tap in i don't know that's right
when did you get a cherry tattoo so
y'all know i'll be wearing my
my little 2000 temporary tattoos i'm so
scared to get my body tatted because
it's so beautiful and someone told me
you don't put a sticker on a band or
bentley and your girl is definitely you
know a high priced item
so i'll be going back and forth i love
me a good tattoo moment but i'll just be
playing with y'all
all right y'all thank you for your
questions and you know how to clear up a
couple things
until next time the icy girl loves y'all